okay are you ready for something that's
not CDC a beer Debbie the committee
actually was introduced to an
intervention that's more locally grown
you could say and it's called think
twice it's an individual level
single-session peer delivered
intervention for men who have sex with
men and the intervention focuses
primarily around commonly used
grassroots form of prevention called
Ciro sorting you heard a little bit
about zero sorting in some earlier
presentations today basically what Sarah
sorting is is limiting partners to those
of your same status so positive people
looking for positive partners negative
people looking for- partners the
intervention uses a graphic novel to
deliver the intervention content and
you'll see what that is in just a minute
some theory and evidence think twice is
a theory based on behavioral
intervention animal at Lisa talked to
more about that it was tested among both
white and african-american men who have
sex with men and the short-term outcomes
demonstrated substantial reductions in
numbers of sexual partners among
participants so what am I do now is ask
dr. Lisa Ian she's a postdoctoral fellow
at Sierra to come up and talk to you
about think twice she worked on the
design in the study of think twice with
a Yukon psychologist Seth Kalesh man who
many of us are familiar with as he
developed the Debbie healthy
relationships that many of us implement
so i'd like to welcome Lisa
okay um well I'm I'm very happy to be
here and I'm happy you are all here and
I'm really excited for the great turnout
um yeah and thank you for the
introduction that was kind of my whole
talk but it's cool now I'm kidding
kidding kidding but um no no so I hope
not cuz I I do about 18 slides so
anyways the title of the talk is the
development and outcomes of an
intervention to address Sarah sorting
among HIV negative men who have sex with
men and I don't just for the record I
don't like the term MSM either but we
end up kind of sticking to it because we
know that we have men in our study who
say that they are straight and they are
definitely having unprotected sex with
other men so so that's what happens okay
so as I'm sure you're all familiar the
incident HIV level has been rising and
the last time was estimated it was about
56,000 incident infections and of course
men who have sex with men are
disproportionately affected by HIV they
make up about half of all new infections
and some of the estimates vary but
somewhere between two to five percent of
the male population so clearly sharing a
huge burden of incident HIV infections
so what exactly is going on so what are
MS m doing that's placing themselves at
risk for HIV infection well in looking
at the literature on it we know that MSM
are continually continuing to engage in
high rates of unprotected sex okay and
what are some determinants of these
unprotected sex acts well some things
that we say over and over again in the
literature and feedback that we get from
focus groups are things like safer sex
fatigue HIV treatment optimism there's a
lot coming out on that in the past few
years so people just thinking that HIV
is more of a chronic illness and that
medications for HIV are really good and
that you can be HIV you know you can
chronically infected and be on
medication
and lead a normal life and then
substance you sussed I mean HIV
prevention since the very beginning of
the epidemic that's something that's
come up over and over again okay but one
thing I'm going to focus on in
particular is Sarah sorting says
mentioned Sarah sorting is limiting
unprotected sexual partners to those who
are of the same HIV status okay so
hiv-positive men having sex with
hiv-positive and hiv-negative and having
unprotected sex with HIV negative men
and this strategy is is actually
commonly reported among MSM when we
survey them on it and it's really a
grassroots form of prevention so
although Sarah sorting has only more
recently been looked at in the
literature say like in the past about
five years or so we can document that
it's been going on since the beginning
of the epidemic as well there have been
sex parties for hiv-positive men since
like mid 80s okay so it's been going on
for a while but we're really just
starting to focus on it now and what it
means what it means to men and and what
it means in terms of from a public
health standpoint and essentially it's
an alternative condom use so if you're
only having sex with people of the same
HIV status in theory you don't have to
worry about it okay well the problem is
is that in practice we know it's risky
how do we know it's risky so in studies
looking at men who are not just recently
diagnosed but recently HIV infected when
we asked them when we say to them okay
well tell me what you've done for the
past few months in terms of what
behaviors have you engaged and many of
them their greatest risk for HIV
infection is reporting sex with a man
who they thought was HIV negative okay
so we so we know based on that data and
then there's also more recent
longitudinal data coming out looking at
men who always use condoms men who Sarah
Soren men who have unprotected sex with
hiv-positive and hiv-negative partners
and those men whose sarah sort there
there also some of them are also Sarah
converting as well so
and then there's it's not there's a
modeling study the interesting modeling
study of Sarah starting it's not exactly
a comprehensive model of Sarah sorting
but it brings up some really important
points so just bear with me for this one
because it's it's kind of
counterintuitive so what so in this
particular modeling study by Butler and
Smith what they found was that for for
men who's HIV negative it's actually
riskier for that man to have unprotected
sex with a man who's believed to be HIV
negative from a higher risk population
than it is for that man to have
unprotected sex with a man who's
hiv-positive and on treatment and the
reason for that is this if you're HIV
positive and you're on treatment you're
it's likely that your viral load is
under control and therefore you're less
infectious whereas if you select a man
who's believed to be HIV negative from a
higher risk population there's a chance
that they're acutely infected they are
acutely HIV infected and they don't know
that okay Ike a standard test don't
don't detect that and if you're acutely
infected then you're you have a high
viral load because you don't have an
immunological response so you're also
hot more infectious okay so it gets a
little bit complicated but that for sure
is undermining Sarah sorting that that
type of scenario okay so and really at
the center of Sarah sorting is that you
have to have accurate information about
your own and your partner's HIV statuses
and this is very difficult information
to ascertain so one thing that one thing
to look at of course is HIV testing in
our own studies looking at a men who
reports arrow sorting what we found is
that they on average there last HIV test
was 14 months ago and they've reported
for sexual partners in the past six
months okay so there Sarah Sarah doing
they're relying on this test result from
14 months ago and they've had a lot of
sex
they've had a lot of different partners
in that time frame so that information
is not accurate right and and
essentially even if you test let's say
you know even if you test often it you
can really never test often enough for
HIV to be certain of your status if
you're engaging in high-risk behavior
because of the cute infection right so
either way it HIV testing really is a
form of prevention in terms of relying
on the information to reduce the
likelihood of being HIV infected and
then also one thing that Sarah sorting
does Sarah sorting for HIV infection at
least one thing it doesn't consider is
other sexually transmitted infections so
if you're not taking into consideration
things like gonorrhea chlamydia syphilis
herpes all these other potential
infections the problem with that is that
in the presence of those infections you
can be more infectious and also more
likely to be infected if you have an
active infection okay so that also
undermines Sarah sorting okay so what
can we do to address some of the risk of
Sarah sorting well one thing we know is
that risk reduction counseling is
effective so in there two important
components of sexual risk reduction
counseling that are even more critical
when designing a Sarah sorting
intervention one of which is tailoring
to the individual and the other which
i'll get i'll get into greater detail on
and the other is feasibility so we all
know that this has to be feasible given
the tools that we have in the setting
that it's going to be done in in one
form of sexual risk reduction counseling
is a single session intervention and
it's kind of a something that I focused
on a lot because to me these are much
more feasible than a multi session
intervention when you're trying to get
people to come back multiple times and
so on and so forth and also because they
can fit into existing health care
infrastructure more easily than a more
complicated intervention and so a single
session intervention is
exactly what it says it is it's one
contact with a client or one contact
with the participant and in a review of
these studies we found that the evidence
for effectiveness of a single session
intervention is actually comparable to
the evidence for the effectiveness for a
multi-session intervention so it's
really good news and also single session
interventions have been demonstrated to
reduce risk behavior and not only risk
behavior but biological outcomes so
looking at sexually transmitted
infections so we see a decrease as a
result of having gone through a single
session intervention and as I had
mentioned these they're a potentially a
reasonable option for health care
setting okay so cuz not only are they a
minimal burden but they are more likely
to be able to fit into the existing
services that are already being provided
okay so what would a sarah sorting
intervention look like so now i'm going
to get into more the details on think
twice so think twice is a single session
one-on-one peer counselor delivered
brief intervention it's about 40 minutes
and okay so I'll talk a little bit first
about the recruiting for the for this
intervention that we did we went to we
engaged in active recruitment and we use
various forms so we went into bars we
went into parks we went into treatment
centers we went into other organizations
that were providing services we sent out
flyer we just covered this this study
was actually done in Atlanta so yeah it
was it was guided by people in in
Connecticut but was done in Atlanta but
it was done in both rural and urban
areas of Atlanta and we had success with
with both of those settings for the more
rural areas we did we had people call us
we set out flyers to everywhere we could
we thought that people would congregate
and they called us in to be screened
over the phone and then for the more
urban areas of course that's when we did
the active recruitment at the bars and
so on and so forth and as has been
mentioned you really need people who are
engaging and they're fun
and they have a lot of good energy
because in a sense you're not only
trying to get people to bind to the
intervention but initially you're trying
to get people to buy into the person the
person who's presenting the information
and let's see so what we found was that
we probably in the course of maybe two
or three months we had about two or
three recruiters working at any given
time and we must have we must have
contacted a few thousand people so we
were really able to cover a lot of
ground and we also use the internet as
well so we found that craigslist was
really effective it's about twenty-five
dollars to post two to make a posting
for you can put it in the employment
section of craigslist and you can give
all the details of a study and and that
was that's very useful we also use
adam4adam in manhunt not calm to
maintain those profiles and another
thing is what we did is we actually
hooked up with club promoters bar owners
people who are really in the know what's
going on the night scene and that was
very very effective in terms of getting
us a foot in the door so the thing the
thing twice intervention self now I'm
going to talk a little bit about that so
think twice really the focus of it is
mainly on providing information about
Sarah sorting about selecting sexual
partners and also coming up with a real
world doable plan so and we there's
there's minimal materials there's a
graphic novel that we created for the
story or for the intervention and this
actually was a very effective way of
being able to talk about personal things
about people's sexual lives in all while
you're trying to build rapport as well
because you got a short amount of time
when you're trying to pack a lot of
information into it so what we did is we
used a fictional character though the
story's evidence-based it's the story of
Mike and he in the beginning of the
graphic novel
he tests HIV negative and he uses things
like Sarah sorting and strategic
positioning and questions about viral
load some of the things that have been
mentioned earlier to stay safe and but
at the end of the story he ends up
testing HIV positive and that what the
counselor does with the client or with
the participant is works their way from
the end of the story to the beginning of
story talking about the ways Mike
potentially put himself at risk for HIV
infection and then of course it's
possible that he was acutely infected at
the beginning of the story when he
tested HIV negative so all these things
about Sarah sorting and these other
strategies that men are using can be
mentioned just by going through this
graphic novel and then there's something
interesting that happens during the
intervention so you say to the man once
you've gone through the story and talked
about these different strategies and how
they're effective or ineffective you say
to them okay well how did you relate to
Mike you relate to my cat all the lead
character of the story and they would
always say no no no I don't really know
okay so and so then we work we have a
feedback kind of like a feedback report
that would work through it's very short
it's it's about three pages and we say
okay well let's talk about you and tell
me tell me about the partners that
you've had in the past six months or in
the past year and let's talk about what
you did with those partners and what
their status was and we had when they
were tested and what position you were
in I mean the whole shebang okay and
then they would kind of say uh huh yeah
I get it i am mike i do you get it now
so so we I mean I refer to as a
teachable moment it's kind of like worry
you've you know turn the light on and
somebody's mind i got them really
thinking about what they've been doing
what they've been putting what they've
been doing to put themselves at risk and
and then we say and then the point is to
come up with a real-world reasonable
plan and that's that's really where the
theory of the intervention
comes in which is conflict theory of
decision making so we've really bought
into this idea of informed decision
making all right so you're going to get
I mean the idea is to give men all the
information give men the facts about
what's going on and then let them use
the facts to come up with their own plan
for what's going to work what's going to
work for them in according to conflict
theory of decision making what happens
is is that you get both the idea is to
take all the different behaviors you've
been engaging in all the things you want
to do all the things you're worried
about all the ways in which are worried
about placing yourself at risk work
through those things to come up with a
plan that you can not only be happy with
but also feel comfortable with okay and
we really the goal is to really get the
the client to buy into it all right and
the hope is is that it will will
eventually result in the best decision
for them and here's just a simple kind
of conceptual model of what I mean when
I'm talking about this informed
decision-making so as I as I mentioned
it's taken kind of like all these social
cognitive factors that go on when when
selecting sexual partners and weighing
the costs and the benefits associated in
reviewing all these decisions and then
making a final decision so just just a
few details on the actual testing of the
intervention itself we had about 150
people in this intervention and I'll
just say that these men were screened
for for sexual risk behavior so these
men had reported to unprotected anal sex
partners in the past six months and you
can see there they're about in their
late twenties some college there is a
considerable amount of drug and alcohol
use in this particular population
they're mostly african-american and
white and about half had reported ever
having an STD which is just fairly high
so they're they're they're a higher risk
population and this is the main the main
outcome from the intervention so this is
an
number of male sexual partners and you
can see at the to the left at the
baseline they reported on average about
four sexual partners for both the
intervention in the control group and
then at one month you see a decrease in
the number of sexual partners being
reported among men who went through the
think twice intervention and then you
see the the same decrease at the
three-month mark as well so shown to be
effective in terms of reducing the
number of partners at short-term
outcomes so essentially when I mentioned
I had talked a bit about feasibility of
inter of an intervention the idea for
think twice it was really designed
around being able to incorporate it
during routine HIV testing and
counseling so I know right now many of
you are using the the CDC based
guidelines for testing and counseling
well this could be used as a form of
post-test counseling so for men who test
HIV negative and if you're wondering
about HIV positive and I've I can talk
about that as well but just just for
this talk I'm just talking about HIV
negative men so if you if you test HIV
negative this intervention is designed
to be given as as a post-test form of
counseling ok and then essentially just
in some we know that blanketed messages
for risk reduction are not sufficient
more and more we're seeing that informed
decision-making is is really a more
effective form of coming up with a risk
reduction plan because it not only
allows for making educated decisions but
it also prepares men for when they're in
a situation where they're at risk and
they need tools and skills to reduce the
risks that they're facing so that